[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this event which is called in
the name of love what an actually love
not love love conquers all and that's a
motto central to our culture and it's
Christian heritage yet Buddhists think
of love as an obstacle to enlightenment
Nietzsche went further and called love
barbaric for it is practiced at the
expense of others is love for all an
illusion might we be better to see love
as a dangerous force that by its nature
excludes others and gives rise to
conflict or is love for our closest our
family and tribe all that really matters
so I think this is what we're trying to
get at really this conflict or potential
conflicts between the idea of loving one
person at the expense of others or
whether a more kind of all-inclusive
comprehensive love is possible right our
speakers to my left
Phillip blonde an Anglican theologian
and a director of the Res Publica
think-tank is the author of red Tory how
left and right have broken Britain and
how we can fix it which is an argument
for a radical new way to fix a broken
country to my left and the costume gives
it away doesn't Cullinane hardly is an
anglican bishop and academic and the
first woman trained and ordained as a
priest in the Church of England to
become a bishop in the Anglican
Communion most recent book is thinking
about the Bible and last but not least
on my right mark Salter a consultant in
adult General Psychiatry mark he's a
media expert at the Royal College of
Psychiatrists and has worked as a
broadcaster for BBC and ITV I'm going to
come to you mark first if that's okay
your opening thoughts on this this this
notion is love for all a dangerous
illusion is it possible to love one
person as well as lots of people what
are the costs and benefits involved okay
well first we're going to start out by
defining love I think it's for the most
important thing
and I probably be swept Ria's is anyone
here who doesn't breathe
what's obvious question but is there
anyone here who thinks of lack of
breathing or oxygen as an appetite do we
have an appetite for oxygen if you ask
about appetite for food it's quite clear
we know what we mean by that term and
I'd like to say we have an appetite for
oxygen the problem being that if we
deprived of it we did within about three
minutes and I would say that we have an
appetite for love which is no less
fundamental in other words it's a
biological thing it keeps us alive it
keeps us ticking sure Darwinian amongst
us will tell us that it's good for
reproduction it helps to love the purse
of you excuse the word shag which is
another word for intercourse or repre
duction another fundamental biological
process but there's no doubt about the
fact that love is essential problem is
that love is not a noun we're using the
word now and already it's process it's a
force but actually the fact of the
matter is that love is a verb a verb
it's something you do when you turn
something into a noun in our West and
civilization you get into a lot of
trouble the word community is a noun and
as a psychiatrist in East London they
can either mean living in are you in so
cardboard box or it can be living in a
well staffed care home or living with
your loved ones community can mean
different things depending on the power
of the noun similarly with depression
it's a thing that's treated with Prozac
no it's not it's treated with love
community is built with love community
is built with this biological force it
needs refining because it's a verb it's
something we do it's an action and like
farting and breathing and suffocating or
singing or dancing and walking or
defecating and all the other things that
it means in this group II mess of being
a human being we can get better at it if
you work at it if we devote our lives to
it then you don't have to have a one
noun fits all model like so much of our
world does because we can damn nor do it
for the one and the greater I haven't
got time to talk about attachment theory
now hopefully we'll come on to that and
I'd like to mention John Bowlby but the
important thing is that it's an equation
where love equals one plus one equals
greater than two
good laugh means that the individual is
synergistically attached to a person and
is better for it but remains an
individual for all that you don't merge
into each other that's crucial
so whilst your question very simply put
love it is I think yes one can perfectly
coexist love before one can easily
coexist with love for you all as long as
we do it skillfully
that's my point okay thanks mark so
loves more of a verb than a noun we can
work on it and it's essential but not
reducible to biology I think that's what
you're saying is okay brilliant thank
you very much Helen Ann over to you
thank you good morning everybody and did
anybody watch the Eurovision Song
Contest last Saturday anybody admit to
that well I did the Danish entry was a
song called lovers forever and the next
day I was preaching on a text from
John's Gospel where Jesus says a new
commandment I give to you that you
should love one another as I have loved
you so I think the idea of is love for
all a dangerous ideal yes it is but
perhaps in the classically Anglican way
I might add a but to that because it
does depend as Mark said on how you
define love and the foundation narrative
that I would base that on is the
collection of books that make up the
Bible which are many and varied written
by different authors over a vast amount
of time in history many different
contexts and containing different sorts
of words for love so I'd want to ask
that question what exactly do we mean by
love by far and away the most common
word for love in the New Testament is
that word agape which has to do with
community rather than self but the idea
of love being a dangerous ideal really
is is summed up in this symbol that I I
wear around my neck the cross and a
parable that Jesus told in the New
Testament is the parable of the prodigal
son maybe you've heard of it it's kind
of one of these stories that's pretty
common narrative two sons one spends all
the father's inheritance goes away has a
lot of parties etc the oldest son is a
bit annoyed about this because the
younger son basically squanders
everything comes back is received with
great celebrations and the oldest son
kind of goes that's not fair or the
point of that story and the point of
love in a way is to say it's not fair
because it does involve huge
vulnerability and risk and cost and in
the sense you can't have an assertion of
love without having that shadow side of
risk and vulnerability and loss
so yes love is love for all is a
dangerous ideal thank you hello
yes sir love for all is a dangerous idea
and it makes us vulnerable creates risk
but the Bible perhaps gives us some
clues as to how to manage that thank you
very much over to you for that what's
your initial take on this as a
philosopher and theologian I always find
one of the most successful ways to think
is to be imagine what the world would be
like if the quality you were talking
about didn't exist Adorno call it the
power of the negative so in almost
anything you talk about it's worth
thinking well what if it didn't exist or
what if the proxy for this word didn't
exist what would the world be like what
I think is interesting about love is is
we don't realize it's absolute
foundational importance I'm going to
talk about love ontologically first of
all or ontology means is what is being
and this very interesting point in Greek
philosophy the further the first the
interesting point about Greek philosophy
is why did it end why did it stop and
the last great Greek philosophers
plutinos
and Platina says philosophy was what's
called a hen ology hen beak the Greek
word for one we're out of the one sprung
the many and all things and st.
Augustine said of platanus that he could
never explain why the one was not
satisfied with itself
why did the universal create all these
things that shared in the universe and
this in the way is the question to put
to Plato and Aristotle and Plato and
Aristotle all agreed there were
universals so this is the great insight
of of Greek philosophy though there are
things called universals and in Plato's
sophist
Plato talks about how universals don't
exist outside of their examples so there
isn't a world where there's just an
archetype of a horse there's a world in
which there are thousands and thousands
of horses and we know they're related we
know they possess hoarseness but that
hoarseness doesn't exist apart from its
examples now why this matters is because
and why Christian philosophy ultimately
triumphed over Greek philosophy but
triumph not in the sense of subjugation
produced and new and I think true hybrid
is it can explain why there are many
things that also share one thing and
that explanation is love what love does
at the most foundational level is
explain why there are more things other
than one thing and it also explains or
attempts to explain the relationship
between things to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas